nobody predicted that once girls and
women caught up with boys and men that
they would keep going and that we would
now have a big agenda Gap in higher
education than we did 50 years ago just
the other way around so we've flipped
the inequality now and it's actually
wider now than it was when I was born
that's an extraordinary fact that no one
predicted
what do you think about the term toxic
masculinity
uh I think it's a toxic term
it escaped from the the margins of
Academia in about in 2016 not not
coincidentally
um and just became a term that was used
to apply essentially to any Behavior by
boys and men that the user disapproved
of uh it's rarely defined uh without any
specificity at all and so it's a in a
sense it's a completely vacuous term but
it's worse than that because by putting
those two words right next to each other
it actually repels a lot of boys and men
from a conversation about what it means
to be a man what it what it means to be
particularly mature I think to talk
about mature masculinity and immature
masculinity is quite useful but the idea
of toxic it's like Puritan it's like
it's ideal it reminds me the idea of
original sin in Christian theologies
right and and you need these exorcisms
you need someone to come and exercise if
you just weren't so male you'd be okay
and having raised three boys to
adulthood I gotta tell you that idea is
something toxic in them has to be
expunged is not a helpful way to raise
them so uh if we could if we could just
consign that particular term back to the
obscurity of academic journals that
would be great where did it come from
it was originally uh from uh from work
that was being done with incast very
violent incarcerated prisoners uh and so
there are a couple of academics that
were using it to talk about ways in
which you know very violent man who was
serving long prison sentences how their
views of masculinity had become
intertwined with ideas of expressed
violence and dominance and so on too and
and so it was a it was a concept that
was being used by a few psychologists
but but I think it had sort of it was
mentioned five times a year in academic
journals until 2016 and then overnight
it was on the front page of every
newspaper and so it it skept so you know
I think it did have some value in the
sense that there may be a a group very
small group of men for whom actually
their sense of what it means to be male
has in some ways become toxic but it was
always this tiny minority of men for
whom it was ever useful to apply it and
then suddenly Donald Trump got elected
need to
Etc and you know there you go I've heard
you say that it's a actual term to use
when one finds the behavior of any man
offensive or unpleasant and that's so
correct it's gone from being something
that's an aberration a complete outlier
to anything which is just slightly
objectionable
yeah that's the problem with it is that
there are many problems with it but like
any of these terms if it just expands
and expands and expands so everything
you know I think I I just did a quick
search around and discovered that
everything from climate change to covid
to war to is the result of toxic
masculinity and you know if there was
resistance to getting vaccinated it was
toxic masculinity if you make a pass
it's toxic masculinity and and it was
just like being and actually there was
this I talk about this in my book there
was an incident that my kids High School
uh that got International attention as
an expression of toxic masculinity which
really woke me up to the way this term
has been sort of thrown around and used
indiscriminately
um but as I say it's not just it's not
just vacuous it's actively harmful and
interesting a lot of feminists will say
that now too there's a lot of people at
Helen Lewis who writes the Atlantic and
so on they're just saying look this term
is not helping us it's actually pushing
men away from a conversation about
masculinity and can we please stop using
it and so this is not a you know a right
wing View at all it's actually one that
a lot of feminists are just looking at
the data and saying if the goal here is
to have a good conversation with boys
and men about what it means to boys and
men this is not the way in it's a
terrible frame for that conversation it
seems strange to me that something odd
happening in the modern world at the
moment because the male default it looks
like has become sort of the preferential
life path that's being pushed on to
especially women that sort of lean in
Boss [ __ ] career woman with the ability
to have no strings attached casual sex
and high Financial independence without
family but this is also while typically
masculine values of things like
aggression or emotional control or
conquery or Mastery have also become
demonized so it is this very strange
situation that's going on at the moment
and I've been asking a lot of people
about why it is that women
are being told to be more more masculine
in a way why would that be seen as
something that's preferential why is
that something that's that's
pedestalized in a way
well I think that there I mean there are
certain virtues or traits or strengths
that may be traditionally associated
with one sex or the other and you know
to make the boring social science point
up front these are averages the
distributions overlap can we just edit
that into every pretty much every
sentence we're going to use because
otherwise people think that like that
it's a dimorphic distribution not a not
a binary one
um and I do think there are some
elements of this that like to the extent
the kind the aspiration leadership
Ambitions on it it to the extent that
those were previously seen as quotes
masculine if women are now being
encouraged to express those that's a
good thing I mean that's what Liberation
is about that's what equality is about
um without anybody male or female being
forced into a box whether that's the old
box of stay-at-home wives you know don't
trouble yourself with the labor market
love approach or a new box which is this
is how you must be you know everyone has
to be like Jeff Bezos instead we want a
world that allows us to flourish in our
own way
I will say that some of those terms
you've just used about sort of you know
female aspiration
um are important not to kind of
misunderstand because they are against
of course the history of lots of women
being told the opposite right so there
is something empowering about women
saying you can be everything and it's
also important to note that whilst there
is a bit of a panic about fertility in a
lot of countries right now
I don't share that Panic really you know
most women are having children most
women do want children and so if you
look beyond the pages of a few Elite you
know media Outlets that are catering to
you know a very small group of Highly
Educated 30-something men and women most
people are having kids uh and so you
know the the 35 year old in New York or
London orever is not necessarily the
median person we should be worried about
and so I don't share this view that you
know all of a sudden we're surrounded by
childless women that's just not true
there is a rise in childlessness but we
shouldn't freak out about it in the way
that I see some social conservatives
doing interesting yeah that's an
interesting input I think
one of the things that I found very
interesting after I spoke to a friend he
said
my current belief is that male
self-improvement sees the person as
mutable and the world is immutable so
you need to be the best person possible
while accepting the rules and
environment you are in this is in
contrast with female self-improvement
which sees the person as immutable and
the world is mutable so women are taught
to accept yourself and try to change the
support structures in society that's
around you I'm not sure that that's true
across every situation but there's
something similar where you talk about
the problems of boys and men are
structural in nature rather than
individual but are rarely treated as
such the problem of men is typically
framed as a problem of men it is men who
must be fixed one man or boy at a time
yeah and I I think it's a really
interesting and well observation but uh
I think in some ways it's important to
get a bit of a history here so I think
right now there is a focus within the
women's movement
um using that term broadly uh around
structures so structures of care you
know Child Care Health Care you know
workplace flexibility and so on but it
wasn't that long ago
um that it really was much more
individualized it was about empowerment
you know remember assertiveness training
I mean that was a huge thing in the
women's movement for a while it's like
what women need to do is be more
assertive so when you send it for more
assertiveness training and if you're not
getting a pay rise it's because you're
not being assertive enough
um and even today you've got the whole
power stance thing you know like which I
think has been now completely debunked
the revocation crisis came and
decapitated just completely debunked
yeah but um but like all things that get
headlines and then get debunked no one
knows about the debunking
um we can we could all have a long list
everyone
stood like this yeah I've been doing it
and then you and then you read the
debunking it's like God I just wasted
you know a year of my life standing like
an idiot but so I do think like this
this balance between is this about you
or is it about Society is important when
your friend really kind of captures that
well and I do think the women's movement
has moved on towards more structure but
I I also think that it's true to say and
you just kind of quoted me on this that
as far as men are concerned
pretty much everyone seems to agree that
it's about the individual that men need
to fix themselves in a way that in a way
that kind of older style feminism did
for women
um and and and not try and change the
world around it and what that results in
is a sort of Unholy alliance between a
progressive left that says a toxic
masculinity that's to blame for all
men's problems or or you know rare God
misogyny and a populist right that says
it's because men aren't manly enough
anymore and so the left essentially says
you just need to be like your sister and
you'll be okay and the right says you
need to be like your dad and you'll be
okay and meanwhile us men in this world
of more gender equality trying to figure
this out and neither of those messages
are very helpful so the structure of the
education system which we might get to
is definitely less friendly to male
structurally uh the labor market has
changed in ways that structurally have
had a disproportionate effect on men you
know it's not de-industrialization free
trade automation etc those are gender
neutral changes on their face but
they've had a much bigger impact on men
and that's just a fact and then the
shift in the economic relationship
between men and women has significantly
changed family structures in a way
that's challenged what it means to be a
father so in various ways those are
structural change those are the
environment to use your friends terms
the environment isn't immutable in fact
the environment's been I mean it's just
been like a kaleidoscope around men and
women for the last few years right it's
just been this dizzying cultural change
and so recognizing that is part of I
think uh is a necessary step to making
progress which is not to absolve
individuals of responsibility for what
they do with their lives certainly not
the message I've sent to my boys I do
want them to be counted and be
responsible but it's crazy to imagine
that people are learning working and
living in some kind of vacuum
what's happened to males in education
then
what's happened is that males have
fallen rapidly behind females at every
stage of the education system and in
every Advanced economy in the world so
if you just take the all the oecd
countries such a pretty good proxy for a
decently economically Advanced there are
more young women with a college degree
than young men in both the UK and the US
it's of 60 40 now on college campuses
and that's happened incredibly quickly
you know when I was born in 1969 it was
about college campuses were about 70
male 30 female by the time I went to
college in the late 80s it was about 50
50 and now it's flipped to 60 40 the
other way and so on pretty much every
measure you can look at
um girls are ahead of boys and that's
increasingly true even established like
math and science so one of the ideas
people have in their head is like oh we
always knew girls were better at English
and women better at English and those
sorts of subjects but aren't boys much
better at math and science
but the answer is not really anymore
um you know in most places now the the
girls and women have caught up on the in
the in math and science as well and in
some cases overtaken and still have this
huge lead in literacy in English and
literacy in English turn out to be more
important for what happens to you after
that so there's been this huge
overtaking which by the way no one
predicted it's really interesting go
back and you read the stuff in the 70s
when we were really pushing for gender
equality in education to get more women
into college and especially into more
male dominated subjects and everybody
was pushing towards parity nobody
predicted that the lines would keep
going nobody predicted that once girls
and women caught up with boys and men
that they would keep going and that we
would now have a big agenda Gap in
higher education than we did 50 years
ago just the other way around so we've
flipped the inequality now and it's
actually wider now than it was when I
was born almost and certainly us it's
wider and I think in the UK it's getting
close so that's an extraordinary fact
that no one predicted and can only be
the result of structural factors if it's
happening everywhere
and every level is not the kid right
it's not Chris's problem in secondary
school in a particular education system
you know or my son's problem in the US
K-12 it's it's as a structural problem
with the education system that's just
not male friendly enough
structurally what's changed then because
just that more women are going to
college and more women are performing
better doesn't mean that men should be
doing worse
no and it's important to distinguish of
course as you imply there between
relative and absolute right so if if one
group is doing better than another then
by definition
that the other group's doing relatively
less well it's like a gender pay Gap
right so uh the fact that women are
earning a huge ton more than they were
50 years ago but that doesn't mean
they're caught up with men yet so uh
absolutely wages have gone up
um but in some in some cases as the
absolute educational performance of boys
has flattened or has dropped and so if
you look at white working class boys in
the UK for example or black boys in the
US actually in some in many areas
they're actually sliding backwards and
but you're right to kind of point to the
distinction between relative and
absolute what I think has happened
is that the education system is just
structured in favor of women and girls
because it it rewards certain kinds of
behaviors at critical ages in particular
turning your homework in being planned
for being organized being committed
sticking on the task being future
oriented about the age of 16.
which is when the gender gap in those
skills is at its widest and so what
happens is the girl's brains just
develop earlier than boys it's just a
biological fact and in particular in the
in the prefrontal cortex this bit of the
brain that's the CEO of the brain it is
the bit that turns your homework in that
that says it's the bit of your brain
that stops you going to the party and
makes you stay in studying chemistry
right
it's the bit of the brain that every
parent waits to develop in their sons
basically parenting is like a a 10-year
process of being the substitute
prefrontal cortex for your boy have you
got kids have you got Sons no not yet
all right well trust me that's what it
is you're basically just going to be
their prefrontal cortex until when is it
coming when is it coming and the answer
is much later than in girls and so it's
no surprise that girls are doing better
the surprises that they weren't doing
better before why weren't they doing
better before because of sexism
the truth is that girls were always at a
structural advantage in education but we
couldn't see it because it was never
expressed in things like college going
exam taking and so on because they were
preparing for a life of being a wife and
mother
as soon as we took the prayer time in
the structural advantage that women had
was exposed so in a sense by leveling
apparently leveling the playing field in
education
what we revealed was that the women are
much better players
and they are as a result largely in my
view of development it's also true that
we don't have enough male teachers that
the pedagogy is not male friendly and so
on to there's a whole bunch of things
going on but taken as a whole you look
at the school system it's impossible to
come to any conclusion other than that
this suits girls better than it does
boys that's fascinating the fact that
this has always been lurking below the
surface this has always been the way
that the population within schools has
been performing but because of lack of
access lack of encouragement
gendered discrimination that has
restricted women from being females from
being able to reach their full potential
in the education system it's only when
you've been able to open up those doors
that the underlying
um disparity has been able to fully show
itself and I suppose that
it's difficult because if that was the
case previously
the Assumption now is that the only
reason there could be a disparity
between boys and girls performance is
now due to some other type of
restriction or sexism it's by boys being
told something restricted in some way so
using the previous model of what was the
solution to the problem for women and
now mapping that onto
the issue that manifesting or boys
so it seems like it's more deep rooted
than that this isn't the sort of thing
yes that is that is occurring in the
culture this is something which is
occurring in biology from a very early
age
yeah it's it's happening in the system
itself that's a that's a great
distinction so I think that the main
problem that the uh women and girls
faced before was they just had breaks on
there just had barriers it was like
didn't go to coming like my my dad went
to college because you know that was the
way he was gonna hopefully earn more
money and be able to raise family my my
mum was basically encouraged to leave
high school at 17 and said do you want
to be a nurse
um and the idea that should have gone I
just would just didn't happen
um you know and so you don't have to go
and it's so quick this change
um that's taken place but you're exactly
right and it's hard I think for people
to get their head around that because
it's happened so quickly that the idea
that people it's tough to get people to
to get their head around the idea that
boys could be a structural disadvantage
in the education system which until
incredibly recently seemed to be serving
poison men much better than girls and
women like literally in the blink of an
eye
and then there's a mistake that's made
along exactly the lines that you've just
identified which is that some people say
oh there must be discrimination against
boys in education and you get books like
the war against boys the war on men Etc
which is that there is intentional
discrimination against boys and there's
almost no evidence
no evidence of that like no one is
saying to but no one said to my boys
when they're going through high school
or don't you worry about college just
find yourself a nice wife and settle
down no one was saying that they were
saying for God's sake turn your homework
in so that you stand a chance of going
to college you idiot so it isn't
discrimination but it it is instead the
mixture of the Chrono the difference
between the chronological age and
developmental age of the average boy and
girl especially in adolescence has been
revealed by by the women's movement and
also progressively teaching as a
profession has become more and more
female over time and so we're a fewer
and fewer male teachers in schools and
that does seem to affect my health
performance or reasons that are complex
and so on too and there's been a bit of
a shift away from styles of learning
that seem a bit more boy friendly and
male friendly like vocational education
for example which does seem to suit on
average overlapping distributions
seem to suit males uh more than females
and so for all so there's been a series
of Trends in education that have that
have I think exacerbated this underlying
structural problem which is a 16 year
old girl is older than a 16 year old boy
in terms of her developmental uh
abilities
just how
big is the
did I hear you say that it was two
percent of kindergarten teachers in
America are male some insanely small
proportion
yeah it's it's about it's about two
percent yeah
um and it's not going up either uh it's
similar in the UK
um these numbers actually do map pretty
well across U.S and you get a one in ten
um uh Elementary School teachers or
Primary School teachers male and in in
uh one of my one of my sons actually
works in early years education so I get
this you know a lot of this you know
through him and he's one of the very few
males of course working in that space uh
and so when you dig into numbers here
it's about two percent which is
very low number and to put it in
perspective as a share of the profession
there are twice as many or even three
times as many women flying U.S military
planes
as there are men teaching kindergarten
and Pre-K classes so we have about three
times as so three times it's about seven
percent seven percent of U.S military
Pilots now women now I'm happy to have a
conversation about whether that's too
low you know what should that number be
and of what's actually happening of
course is that the most the air forces
are doing this to yourself they're
redesigning the cockpits of planes
so that they're not designed anymore
around a presumed kind of male uh height
which will allow shorter men to be
Pilots do
um but it also most important so they're
actively recruiting they're changing the
design of fighter planes to get more
women great
what's happening to get more men into
Early Education
answer
nothing
and so there is isn't even seen as a
problem to be addressed let alone one
that we're propering solutions for and
so it's one of the reasons I'm really
emphasizing this point why would that
matter why would it matter to have male
teachers in schools
there's two big reasons one is because
the evidence suggests that when there
are male teachers in schools especially
in certain subjects like English but
even in early years the boys seem to do
a bit better
in just the same way that girls seem to
feel the better when there are female
teachers especially when it's in
subjects that go against the sort of
stereotypical grain so girls do
especially well when they have female
science teachers but boys do especially
when they have male English teachers
um uh and in the early years there's
some evidence that a bigger mix will be
good for boys in the long run as to why
we don't really know there's a whole
series of theories could be role models
it could be that male teachers have a
more intuitive understanding of male
Behavior so we do know for example that
male teachers and this is through all
levels they're less likely to see a
boy's Behavior as problematic
uh it's kind of prior to a female
teacher they're more likely to
understand it for what it is perhaps as
intuitive redundant but the other reason
I think is that if we're trying to
change gender stereotypes
you know there's a nice line for the
women's movement which is you have to
see it to be it
well I gotta tell you if boys don't see
any men in any of those roles then it's
not surprising that it's tough to get
men to think about changing their lives
so that they feel more of those roles
Gloria Steinem said that the idea we get
about what it means to male and female
comes in our earliest years and so you'd
think in some ways that feminists should
be leading the charge for more men in
those professions because it helps to
break down reduce the power of gender
stereotypes I'm not suggesting for a
moment we're going to get to 50 percent
early years teachers are male any more
than we're going to get to 50 fighter
pilots are female there are some
differences that are not going to
disappear
um not everything we see in the labor
market as a result of socialization but
two percent is definitely fewer than the
number of men who both could and would
be willing to do those kinds of jobs
there was a reply to an article I think
you wrote in the Atlantic by Catherine
page Hardin Paige has been on the show
before and she linked to a study sex
differences in the developmental
trajectories of impulse control and
sensation seeking from early adolescence
to early adulthood they really know how
to name these Journal Publications they
really do everything stuff but I'll uh
the graph will be up on screen and
basically it shows that the age that
boys or men have to be before they have
the same average level of impulse
control as a 10 to 11 year old girl
is age
24 to 25. yeah I know that's like it
does everyone
it does dip a little bit during puberty
to give it its skills as well yes it
does
um yeah it's interesting of course you
know again all the caveats about means
and so on too
um these are these are averages
um but for sure there's a huge
difference in the development of of
impulse control and that's really this
this concern about this prefrontal
cortex so the way that psychologists
talk about impulse control and the other
side it's in the same paper actually so
if we link to the paper the other side
of it is sensation seeking so you've got
impulse control and sensation seeking
and the way to think about that is uh
and this is how psychologists and let's
talk about it it's like the Gap is like
the gas or the the accelerator and the
brake right
um uh and during adolescence you get a
whole lot more accelerator and a bit not
enough break and so that's when you do
the crazy stuff as an impact and then
gradually the two start to balance out a
bit more but two things one is the gap
is much much bigger as that chart
suggests if you add sensation seeking to
it too it's just this huge gap
um uh for boys and for girls so it's
bigger and Adolescence for both much
bigger for boys and girls there's
different boys are just all they're just
all all go very little break for a few
years like tell me something again this
falls into the category of you know tell
my mum something she didn't know right
she didn't need to read the Journal of
adolescence whatever it is
um but also the the impulse control
development does come much later for
boys as that chart shows uh on average
and that's the kind of skill that does
allow you is I said to study chemistry
rather than go out it's the kind of
thing that allows you to just you know
work on your GPA Etc or your uh your
practice for your exams at 16 or and so
on and so it's just that you know those
there's sometimes called soft skills or
non-cognitive skills or whatever you
want to call them that's where the Gap
is it's really important that some
people misunderstand my argument here in
terms of smart Arts that's not that much
difference in the development between
boys and girls but what really counts is
actually it is those skills it is
organization impulse control and so on
too and that paper that uh Catherine
page Arden did uh with Elizabeth Shulman
and Larry Steinberg who had quite a big
influence on me
something that I've just considered
there I think that on average
girls are more conscientious than boys
females are more than men now that is
something that that you can't that isn't
going to change no matter what you do
with regards to the time that people
begin school any structural issues that
you've got going on in there that is a
gendered skew like men tend to be
stronger than women but what you can
look at doing is where are the areas
where we can begin to close this Gap
what are the sort of tools that we can
use what are the elements of this that
are more mutable rather than immutable
so given the current
nightmare of trying to improve men's
males successes in school whilst not
rolling back the progress that we've
made for girls what's the solution
well one headline solution is the
headline of the Atlantic art who just
referred to the um Catherine page Hardin
responded to is to start Boys in school
a year later than girls
um so in the US it's kind of referred to
as red shirting as the term borrow from
Athletics
because of this developmental Gap
uh your age is a very crude proxy for
development uh and it turns out that
it's that it's the difference for boys
and girls and so my proposal is that you
know whatever whatever the school
starting age is that it should be
staggered and so the boys should be
going in chronologically a year older
than girls and I think that that will
really start to pay dividends for the
boys in adolescence because they will
have developed a bit more of a
prefrontal cortex a bit more impulse
control a little bit at the time to
mature a little bit more and so actually
we'll create more of a Level Playing
Field uh developmentally
um and so that's one that's one proposal
we've already touched on the need to get
many more male teachers especially in
early years and English and the need to
do much more vocational training but but
I I think all what those all of those
reforms share is the characteristic of
structural reforms the other thing I
will say is there is some quite good
evidence that that there are programs
that can help to develop those sorts of
skills it's not like
the chart that we just showed that level
of impulse control is somehow it's not
fixed it is true that on average it's
going to be harder for boys to develop
that skill they don't it's not as
innately strong impulse control in boys
and men actually as it is in girls and
women but we can learn
and you know we can learn to be more
confident and assertive maybe if you
like that but we can also learn impulse
control there's a very good study that
just came out that looked in looked at
five-year-olds and it was specifically
targeted on a disadvantaged boys
teaching them these skills these exactly
the skills you just talked about and it
paid it paid dividends in terms of
lifelong learning there are programs
like Boys Boys to Men in Chicago which
works predominantly with black boys I'm
sure you know about it and it's all
about these skills it's not math it's
how to keep your act together how to be
in the world how to organize yourself
and how to control some of your imposes
about Behavior control too that's just
harder for boys and so there are also
programs that we could invest in much
more and that would be specifically
targeted at boys so that would be a
gendered curriculum almost in certain
elements it would be a gender sensitive
thing yeah I mean there's an argument
for saying look you some of these you
might just say well we'll give it to the
kids that most need it and it'll turn
out to be mostly boys and depending on
the nature of the program but not not
entirely and but that's okay we have
programs that do the opposite
um and it may also be that there are
bits of the curriculum
um but it's the pedagogy and I know that
you've you've you've talked to people
like uh have you had Louise perion yes
yeah
um and I think this whole area of Sex
and the need for porn education in
schools
um is actually one where I think I'd
make quite a strong argument for
separating the Sexes when you're doing
that bit of the curriculum I think
that's a bit of sex ed I think porn Ed
is what we would call it is actually
gonna that's gonna go much better if
you're going to do that just with the
boys because the relationship of boys
and men to pornography is very different
to the relationship of women and girls
and that's a distribution by the way
that doesn't overlap very much right so
some of the distributions we're talking
about they're pretty like
conscientiousness you're right
but the distribution's overlap quite a
lot there right
this one doesn't overlap very much
um it's not it doesn't have a lap at all
but it's it's a very bimodal
distribution when it comes to porn use
and and sex generally is one of the
areas where we see quite talk a bit
about this in the book a big difference
between between men and women and boys
and girls what has been the change in
the labor market then
the big change over the last uh 40 50
years has been and this won't just you
know not won't be a breaking news to you
or to anybody listening probably has
been a big shift away from heavy
industry manufacturing
um that's a result of two a particularly
an advanced economies and that's the
result of two big forces one is more
competition from overseas you know the
the intro the introduction of China into
the World Trade Organization was a big
deal in terms of what it did to
manufacturing jobs in the west
um just because of price competition uh
straightforwardly it's not not that I to
be clear it's not that I'm arguing
against that I'm talking about what the
consequences of it were and the other is
automation some of these some of the
roles uh that will perhaps have been
traditionally performed by men factory
work etc been automated my dad's first
job out of out of uh you know college he
actually got on the Ford graduate
trainees game and was but he had to do
some time on the floor and I tell you
what the Ford factories look a lot
different today than they did in the 60s
and they needed a lot fewer men in there
putting the doors on and stuff is
basically done by robots now and so
those those Trends have particularly
affected male employment and the result
has been a drop in mail labor force
participation and a stagnation in male
wages in uh the first true in every oecd
country in the second true in most oecd
countries in the US actually male male
wages have gone backwards so most men in
the US actually earn less today than
most men did in 79. that's not quite as
sharp in most other countries in most
other countries it's just been very slow
wage growth for men especially in the
bottom half of the distribution at the
top men have seen wage growth
as a result of so this is all against
the backdrop of rising economic
inequality generally
so automation globalization has meant
that the typical Brawn based economy
that we used to have has now been
replaced with a more brain-based economy
what's happened that's caused men to not
adapt to this I mean women were not
working at all they were in the house
and then they just got dumped into the
labor force and they seemed to adapt
they weren't doing washing machines and
cleaning up house tasks around the
domestic area
what caused men to not be quite
somaliable given that they were already
in the workforce
well I think there's a few things one is
that for a lot of the women of course A
lot of it seem like pretty much all
upside in terms of like the economics of
it so for women it was getting into
labor market earning earning money for
themselves uh I mean it was important
even in my own life you know my mum
worked part-time she was an industrial
nurse and so on but actually even though
she wasn't the main Breadwinner it was
important to her to have some sort of
you know uh Econo degree of economic
independence and then you just multiply
that by a factor of 100 for the Next
Generation which is no no you're going
to be economically independent and why
shouldn't we have a better wages why
shouldn't we earn more why shouldn't
that's those are incentives that should
apply to everybody and it has been
striking just the movement of women into
higher end male dominated occupations so
in the professions especially much less
so in lower end so if you look at things
like construction for example
that remains very male dominated
um that not many women on construction
sites but there are a lot of women in
law offices and hospitals and so on too
and so so it's important because that
tells you some of the incentives here
just about economic upward Mobility for
women which is like don't particularly
want to be a laborer but I'd very much
like to be a lawyer
um because of just the obviously the
huge rewards you get from that but there
has been this really interesting shift
in women's identity and the way that
women can take on a lot of these roles
and including like if you do become a
you know fire woman or a construction
but people are going to celebrate that
very few people are going to think
there's something wrong with you anymore
if you become a women engineer or a
woman in construction whereas for men
the identity cost this is like you know
Rachel kranton George akelov had a
article in year 2000 called identity
economics and what it basically said was
when people make it apparently just an
economic decision they're also making an
identity decision what kind of person am
I what does this decision say about me
what does it signal about my identity
and up until this point many of the
areas of strong growth have remained
very female in orientation very very
gender segregated and men have not yet
by and large been able to adjust to a
world in which you're going to have a
better chance of making a good living as
a nurse or some kind of living as a
social care assistant than you are as
say a factory worker or a laborer
um and and so that's a one of big parts
of my argument is that they really need
a kind of cultural transformation around
a lot of those jobs that they do become
more accessible to men and they don't
seem as female because
the the demasculinization if I can put
it that way if some of those other
professions I just talked about didn't
just happen by itself it happened as a
result of concerted intentional policy
effort massive campaigning on the part
of lots of well-funded organizations to
really kind of batter the doors down on
behalf of women but there's no
equivalent on the other side we haven't
really tried yet to help men make that
transition which means that for a lot of
men especially working class men that's
a pretty tough transition for a lot of
them to make they don't see them as male
jobs so you've got the male jobs
disappearing the female jobs rising and
men stuck between the two and the worst
thing that can happen is the politicians
to come up come along and promise that
they can bring back those old male jobs
because a lot of men want to hear that
that that's an incredibly dangerous
message because we can't bring those
mail jobs back and all you're doing is
selling a dream selling a nostalgic
dream rather than helping men adjust to
the world as it is rather than the world
as it used to be and I think a lot of
men are just stuck in the vice between
those two right now that's fascinating
the fact that politicians are running on
a lap basically there's no way that this
is going to happen what are you going to
do you're going to roll back automation
is everyone going to start paying more
for the no no one's going to do that you
want cost of living to go up even more
than it already is and then on the flip
side I I agree that you know talking
about getting more women and girls into
stem fields and getting them to do more
uh of those sorts of subjects in school
in college but there hasn't been the
equivalent push for men to become carers
or nurses or to work in HR or to work as
teachers and I imagine that if you were
this isn't just from a we need to find a
place for men in the workforce this is
how much better could the service be for
the users of that service if you are a
guy that needs care because you have
some disability or perhaps your elderly
I would imagine it is significantly
better for you to be looked after in
some of your more intimate moments by a
male than by a female
and there are no males around and that
to me is it a typically
masculine job not culturally but I mean
you've had Medics on the battlefield for
a very long time you've had the doctors
this is you helping your fellow man to
retain some of his dignity this doesn't
feel like a step down I don't think it
would be too far of a jump culturally to
be able to make this pedestalized again
in something that's praised and
applauded for men to go into and it
would be great for the users of it but
it hasn't been
correct uh and and of course you know
historically I mean it was Florence
Nightingale that turned nursing into a
female profession she she said she
actually and men were men were banned
men were not allowed to be nurses after
Florence Nightingale got her way and
because you just said they are not
equipped for it they can't do it and so
she feminized the nursing profession she
also professionalized it to be fair to
her
um but yeah you're exactly right that's
that's the The Dilemma is that we
haven't really done very much to change
these these roles and I'm glad you
mentioned the point about about users
because when I I know I talk about this
the need to get me into what I call heal
professions health education
Administration and literacy so there's
the acronym to match stamp to mirror
stem right you have to have an acronym
you know that everyone knows that uh so
I'm in the uh you know in the US
especially
um and so
um what we actually see fewer men in
here declining numbers of men in
Psychology social work etc tiny
increases in nursing
um and right now uh only about 15 of
care workers are male David goodheart
had a very good piece actually in I
think in the London Times about this
where there's a discussion about
immigration how are we going to we need
more immigrants to fill these care roles
and his point and he's much more
skeptical about immigration than I am
but his point was well how about trying
to get more men to do these jobs uh and
that again from a Workforce first point
of view but if I was making this
argument again I'd lead with the
argument you just made
which is the users of the services
all right if you're a guy in a care home
and you've got you need to go to the
bathroom and you need help or you need
or even if you're let's say you're a guy
struggling with porn addiction yep I was
literally about to say therapy we're
trying to get more men into therapy to
have conversations that what is it two
percent of men it's like a 10 10x
difference between the number of men in
therapy and women in therapy you get to
fix the labor force issue you get to
give men jobs you get to make the users
of that service have a better experience
because the people they're speaking to
they can resonate more with and
downstream from that those people are
more well balanced which means that they
become better members of society all the
way down
exactly and when you when you see such a
strong set of arguments for something
then I think it's really hard not to
come to the conclusion that we shouldn't
do stuff about that that we shouldn't
have like concerted efforts and I you
know I we I want male only scholarships
to encourage men into those sorts of
professions Etc I want subsidies to
employers that hire more men into those
roles I want diversity all the things
we've done to get women into stem
we should be doing the same right now
it's quite hard even to get past the
other people what only men are going to
benefit from this scholarship like yeah
you betcha because that's what we need
for all the reasons you've just said if
we agree that that's important so we
realize as a society we needed to do
more to help women break some of these
barriers down so we threw money and
political capital and institutional
power at that problem and it's been
great
we need to do exactly the same and with
exactly the same level of intention and
force to try and help men get into these
jobs
um and there's ways you can describe
these jobs that are actually just much
more appealing to men you know without
indulging in you know create simplistic
stereotypes there are lots of aspects of
these jobs that actually
are quite male you know quite physical
in many cases as you talked about
dignity and so on too and so without
leaning too hard in stereotypes you can
definitely describe these jobs in ways
that are more appealing to men than we
currently do what about when it comes to
family life what's happening with men as
fathers and husbands and stuff
in some ways I think this is the deepest
problem of all the biggest challenge and
it may run beneath some of the others or
overlap or with some of the others too
which is
the the
primary goal of the women's movement
second wave I guess I'm not very good at
my waves but
um certainly the kind of Steinem wave
was economic independence
was you know post-war especially was to
say women needed to become economically
independent needed to break the chain of
dependency that women had on men that
would make marriage a choice
rather than economic necessity and
rebalance power relationships and so
it's all about material stuff uh
obviously since then feminism's become
much more cultural and ideological but
um and that has been secured to a very
large extent in two ways one by
massively increased employment and
earnings for women and two by the
expansion of the welfare state
especially to help mothers with children
so those two things have basically
broken the chain of dependency that
women used to have with men in the blink
of an eye almost in my lifetime I mean
it's an incredibly short period of time
you know 10 000 years of some kind of
patriarchy 50 years to do a huge amount
of demolition of of that institution
amazing I mean just extraordinary
Revolution that we've seen so they were
right the feminists were right they've
been largely successful the big question
is what does that mean for Dad
If the previous role for dad was
breadwinner largely did other things as
well but it was kind of provider and
that was the relationship we had so with
the with the woman and then they had
kids together
what if she's now a provider doesn't
need him as a provider but she's also
still the main carer
the risk is the dads become redundant
they're just not needed anymore
uh and I think that's the world we're
living in now especially for unmarried
fathers especially for those who are out
of work or who are struggling in the
labor market
um actually they basically get benched
um like who needs them anymore
um because we're in this cultural lag
moment now whereas actually fathers
matter hugely as fathers but there's a a
real problem of fatherlessness
um in many parts of the Western World
now particularly in less affluent areas
working class and it is I think it's
because of this profound shock
that has that is you know hollowed out
the basis for the traditional family
which was economic dependency
uh and great except now what
uh so I think we have a responsibility
to deal with some of the consequences of
even very positive social changes and to
be clear I think we agree that the the
women's movement has been by and large
an incredibly positive change but it has
had a bunch of side effects
and one of them has been to ask real
questions about the role of fathers and
role of men and unless we you know
re-pedestalize to borrow some language
from you fatherhood as an institution in
and of itself I think a lot of men are
going to feel like they're failing
well think about how strange it is that
men
working less
has made them worse fathers men being in
the workforce lesson potentially
spending more time in the home has
somehow made them into less of the
father figure that they wanted to be
yeah that's because we haven't expanded
the role of fathers enough into that
more direct kind of caring role
um and so it is it's got a sense of well
more you know one or the other I know I
know I'll say again from personal
experience like just comparing my father
with my brother so my my dad lost his
job in the recession of the 80s who
obviously worked in manufacturing and he
got up every morning and put his tie on
and had breakfast with us and I asked
him why are you wearing a tie he said
because I have to get another job
and you go and sit in his resume so and
his way of signaling to himself he was
still working the idea that he would
sort of take some time out of the labor
market while my mum
you know took the economic load was
Unthinkable at the time
um whereas my brother he's a doctor and
um you know uh he's taken time he's
taking his parental leave and his kids
are in adolescence because their mum is
also a doctor
and so they have that kind of
flexibility right doctor doctor is a
very very different world
um and he is able to step into that role
much more easily
um than in the past but by and large
that's not happening because
all of us have failed to update our
models of fatherhood for a world of
gender equality and and failed to honor
and valorize the role of fathers as
fathers period dad's matter period
um not just as Breadwinners not just but
period and in some ways
if you're not a breadwinner you matter
even more perhaps and your kids lives
because you're going to be more involved
in their care and so on too well that's
the uh that's the um how would you say
counter-intuitive example that I just
thought of there that when you think
about what a father is at least a little
bit more archaic sort of most of the
1900s it's the one that's setting the
rules perhaps the Taskmaster the one
that goes to work and comes home they
are uh creating a role model that's hard
work and conscientiousness and
discipline and motivation and all this
sort of stuff okay
assessing my own assumptions around
that particular stereotype which part of
that involves fathering not much of that
actually has anything to do with you
being a father it's to do with your
economic utility how you contribute to
the family and some byproduct of it what
are the values of someone that would be
a good economic utility creator
they would be disciplined they would be
a disciplinarian they would be
aspirational so on and so forth okay
well what does it mean
adding another element in that I'd love
to get your thoughts on I spoke to Roy
biomaster uh not long ago and Roy was
talking about the fact that
there seems to be a bit of a question
about why men were needed other than as
sperm donors ancestrally and after a
long
diatribe about what it's not it's not
this it's not that it's not the other he
said it's a hide gun problem he said
that men it seemed mostly were there to
protect they were there to enforce Norms
within the group they were also there as
security from either other tribes or
from animals or from elements to go out
and do things it seems like even the big
game hunting that men went to go and do
netted an energy loss
so the lack of likelihood of them
bringing it down the amount of times
that someone got injured or killed and
the amount of energy that you got back
if you did finally take down the woolly
mammoth or whatever was almost always a
negative however it was great mate
signaling so it was fantastic as a
peacock's tale that look at how
competent I am that I've brought this
down but as women could have absolutely
survived on berries and nuts and things
that they pulled out of the ground so my
question is he went through all of this
was well okay well what is the role of
men if that's the case if we didn't need
them to go and hunt and women they do
aloe parenting you've got the
grandmother hypothesis now for why
menopause occurses so it seems like
women stick about and they do this sort
of shared parenting thing unbelievably
rare even in uh other primates aloe
parenting very very rare it's like the
mother takes care of her child not in
humans it's the mother and the
grandmother and some of the aunties and
sisters and maybe a friend that's and
that's this big big group okay so what's
the use of men I wonder whether
we are seeing again in the same way that
women or females having equal access to
education Unearthed some of the
underlying
um disparities within the system I'm
wondering whether the same thing has
occurred within the family that with
women no longer needing men around that
the
surplusness
of men within the family has now finally
been revealed
so interesting I mean I'd love uh I love
Roy's stuff I cite him quite a bit um
but I've been um
I've been quite influenced by you know
uh
by the work of uh Sarah hurdy and
animation
um Anna matron has a book that uh I
think you'd be very interested in it's
called the life of Dad
she's an Oxford evolutionary
psychologist
um and talks about how fatherhood
developed precisely for the the reasons
that you just hinted at which is the
increased calorific requirements of
raising kids because our brains grew we
needed a lot more calories so it went to
I I botched the number but you know
suddenly it was 13 million calories
whatever to raise a kid
um and actually that was impossible for
her view was that it was impossible for
mums to provide that on their own and so
that's why you that's when fatherhood
became a social institution about 10 000
years ago because the dad if the dad
wanted his kids to survive they needed
more calories than mum could provide and
so he had to get he had to create some
Surplus calories for the kid and that's
the creation of fatherhood in her view
which sounds like it's a different view
to the one the uh the Roy had which is
actually she could have done fine and so
it was just basically
it was like a sport right the big game
hunting big game hunting was the sport
and the other element was The Bodyguard
hypothesis
okay so he could protect you so it's a
way he could show that you could protect
so it wasn't about calories okay so it's
more about the protector than the
provider side of it
yeah well that's very interesting and
Incredibly depressing if true
um I think about the think about the
fact that everything that we've spoken
about so far the changing education has
Unearthed some disparity that very much
pulls the floor out from under where men
thought their position was in society
and this family thing I'm I'm it's the
first time I've thought about it I
didn't even think about it while I was
reading the book and as I'm trying to
join these dots now I I'm gonna have to
email Roy about it and see what he
thinks but it's
I'm dude it feels like a vacuum it feels
like a hole being pulled out you should
have Anna on as well I think um because
that would be useful exchange definitely
I mean it's hard it's hard for me just
to believe just you know what little I
know from Joe henrik's work and able to
and and you know and Catherine page
Harden's work and uh Anna's work and so
on too that it can all be but it's all
protector and I'm pretty sure
an element in this it's it's how much of
that and how much of that is the case
and in a world which has been nerfed
from The Protector role if the
protector's been removed away from it a
little bit more what happens then
yeah one of the protector rollers kind
of it it's certainly at a much practice
become you know significantly less
important in fact a lot of women's
rights groups would say actually the man
in the house is more dangerous than the
man outside the house
um you know so you don't want you're
protecting in terms of a protector role
you see the good police force and good
domestic violence policies and laws
um the provision thing is interesting I
mean my view but in this is again going
back to the sense that like men did
provide they generated a surplus for the
family for the kin for whatever the
group was that they'd had to generate
some kind of surplus colorifically or or
whatever and very often risk their lives
doing so that's why you know Roy is very
fond of this stat that we have twice as
many female ancestors as male ancestors
because the men only have a 50 chance of
reproducing which is why they're more
risk-taking suit too but but if I bring
it up to just what I know from the
Contemporary social science
actually the evidence is quite good that
you know engaged dads
um are good for the dads importantly and
that's very often not said enough and I
don't think I say that enough in the
book honestly but also good for the kids
um you see these long-run outcomes and
it can last a long time so like girls
who have a good relationship with their
dad at 16 have better mental health when
they're 33. but especially for boys I
mean the performance of boys at school
and some of the acting out stuff we
alluded to earlier just much better with
engaged fathers just that's just true
and so what kind of provisioning is
going on there is a different thing I
think so I think the idea that dance are
providing and protecting and teaching is
still all true it's just the nature of
that provision and protect is very
different in the world today so the way
we express what I would argue uh let's
say they're only 10 000 years old
they're still a long time 10 000 year
olds bothering roles and instincts
they're still applicable especially to
adolescents uh I think that's really and
Anna's work is influence on me there's
two animations like actually it turns
out that kind of learning teaching and
pushing the lines a little bit helping
adolescents to navigate risk and learn
how to manage themselves that dads seem
to be a little bit better at that on
average mums tend to be a little bit
better in the very early years when it's
much more about pure nurturing and and
just like everything you do to just keep
the baby safe but actually when it's
time for the when it's time for baby to
start riding a bike and jumping off
walls and whatever it is actually dads
turn out to be a little bit stronger on
that front too so there's a
complementarity I think to the roles of
of mothers and fathers but look
conservatives are worrying for a long
time about this Jeff Dench has his book
back in the 90s now where he said the
family is a myth
but it is a myth that makes men
tolerably useful
and so bowmasters right if baumice is
right then it is a myth and it's always
been a myth and there's game acting and
whatever but it's a myth that we have to
sustain to keep men tolerably useful if
the myth is no longer if the myth dies
then what are we going to do to make men
tolerably useful the thing that
conservatives like guilder and dent and
all that worried about in the 70s was
we're going to make men
they're not going to be you know we're
going to make them Irrelevant for the
reasons we've already discussed and
they're going to form marauding bands of
violent young male syndrome yes yeah
they're having a surplus males all the
Henrich stuff too and it's going to be
like Mad Max basically
um with all these guys they're gonna be
full of testosterone because marriage
and kids lower your testosterone levels
so they're going to have like hyped on
testosterone they're not going to be
economically useful anymore we don't
need them and so they're just going to
form these and Society is going to get
ravaged by as I said this kind of Mad
Max apocalypse the opposite has happened
rates of violent crime have halved in
the last few decades including sexual
assault and so on to our societies has
become progressively more peaceful
uh as men have become less required to
use my language before so their
nightmare scenario has absolutely not
played out I'm much more worried about
the men who are checking out not the men
who are acting out I think that the
checking out of men is a much bigger
problem there's a retreat of males into
basements to indulge in stereotypes
rather than Mad Max Style marauding on
the streets men are not marauding around
on the streets they're retreating
instead
an interesting
consideration here
that I learned about from Diana
fleischmann's paper uncanny vulvas
which is much more interesting to paper
titles not a reference I'm those across
my desk at the Brookings institution but
you're right it's a better reading the
right things Richard you're not reading
the right things and
she
makes a hypothesis that men who utilize
porn and are not going out to seek
partners are getting
simulacrum Fitness cues that they are
being successful
from using porn
and you could roll that uh thought
process forward for well what are
computer games
what's a computer game well that's
progress over time that's
conscientiousness it's a Band of
Brothers You've got community you've got
belonging you've got a sense of all of
this stuff okay so if you are able to
provide proxy Fitness cues that manage
to keep men going and you can basically
sedate them out of being the roving band
of miscreants causing trouble and
pushing over granny that we were
concerned about originally but now
you've got something which is
um less tumultuous but even more sort of
nihilistic
which is this group of sedated checked
out men the checked out thing yeah yeah
they're checked out rather than acting
out yeah I mean I I think that if we
pursue this thought a bit further
um the argument very often is made that
the internet and particularly video
games uh the technology in the form of a
video games especially and pornography
um uh have been you know this is a
horrible thing right and I know Jonathan
height very well and work with him and I
think a lot of a lot of issues there but
you could flip it on its head and say
given what we've seen about a declining
marginal utility of males
actually those things came along just in
time to save us
and even if it's not optimal
and we can get into some of the claims
that you've just made some of which I
I'm more skeptical about than you are I
think
um it's certainly better than the
alternative
right that's very interesting
it's so will we were we are we actually
being saved by games and porn now we're
so focused on the problems that they
might be with those that we're like
what's the counter factual
imagine imagine that we'd had none of
those technological changes at all right
there were no video games for men to
play there was no Pawn for men to look
at and they were increasingly out of
work and dislocated
Etc
uh maybe some of the things that
conservatives warned about would have
been a bit more true maybe wouldn't have
seen this incredible decline in crime
that has the company no one again nobody
predicted that the falling employment of
prime age men
and the growing Detachment of men from
their families Etc would be accompanied
by a historic decline in crime no one
predicted that everybody would have
predicted the opposite of that and so I
think that's important so why and maybe
you've got this this Escape valve in a
way now how bad are those problems
I I'm not convinced that they're that
bad actually I looked at the video
gaming evidence and I just like uh I
didn't
I don't think there's much going on
there I looked at the evidence on porn I
was going to have a whole chapter on sex
it's still there but I cut it out
because there's only so many things you
can you know a friend of mine said like
if you have a chapter on sex you'll
never get people to talk about education
or the labor market
and that's probably good advice
um but I do think that something you've
you've mentioned some you know people
like Louise and there's Christine Ember
and so on too that I think are talking
interestingly about sex I'm not
convinced
for hugely negative effects from porn
either to the extent except for the a
minority who are highly addicted that is
a problem as it is for alcohol or
anything else I think the issue with
things like games and porn you've hinted
at this is is less what
boys and men are doing when they're
doing those things it's more what
they're not doing
it's the displacement of other
activities that's the problem not the
activity itself
and it could be that it displaces say
going out right so I'm old enough to
know that if you wanted to you know to
get any kind of action at all with a
girl you had to go through various
various phases you had to shower you had
to dress properly you had to go out you
had to be you had to risk multiple
rejections until perhaps finally
something happened that broke in your
favor it was humiliating it was
exhausting and you had to do every
Friday and Saturday night from the age
of 15 to whatever it was okay so that's
not the world that my boys grew up in
because there's porn
and there's games and there's weed in it
I'm not I'm not even necessarily sure
that my world was better but I do know
that it was riskier and I do know that
you had to put yourself out there a lot
more and I do know that you had to make
much more of an effort
um and so I worry a little bit about the
ease with which you can opt out of some
of those difficult things like make like
like a mature mating strategy and that
might be de-skilling some young men in
ways that are quite important but I
think I honestly think it's a bit too
early to tell and I'm again a bit
worried about the stereotyping here The
Stereotype well guys just lie around
smoking weed and you know looking at
porn and you know playing video games
and I have three sons in their 20s I can
assure you that young men do lie around
in the basement doing all of those
things but they don't do that all the
time they also have jobs and girlfriends
and college studies and Tennis coaching
and you know so so I'm just it it veers
a bit close to the toxic masculinity
stuff we started with actually if we're
not careful there there are some quite
pernicious stereotypes about men that
that I think can get in the way of
better conversation and these get close
to those for me
it seems to me that this debate about
men's and women's rights is being
treated as a zero-sum game that seems to
be one of the fundamental issues that
we're butting heads against and you say
that people believe arguing for the
rights of men and boys would
automatically mean rolling back women's
rights or denying the existence of
misogyny that has to be probably one of
the Prime flash points when it comes to
putting this forward and how it's going
to be received culturally
yeah I think that's a big a big part of
the problem on both sides I think
sometimes the opposite is true perhaps
on you know on the other side of the
political Spectrum it depends who you're
talking talking to but for sure I think
that one of the problems is that that
even even conceding that we should do
some stuff for boys and men there is a
problem for them is seen as even if not
necessarily diverting resources away
from things for girls and women although
it could mean that it's much much more
about the distraction of attention
it's more of the are you kidding me
problem right it's more the you want me
to talk about boys and men when you know
six percent of companies are led by
women when on your court of
parliamentarians you know and I have my
my wife actually is in the in the
process of raising money uh for a
startup business so I know that only two
percent of venture capital money goes to
female Founders I I'm reminded of that
on a on a nightly basis Chris
um so I'm acutely aware that there's
still a lot of work to do for uh for
women in many areas especially at the
top of society and so it's just a sense
of like
no no we've it's unfinished business
over here a lot of unfinished business
over here and it's really difficult
right now in the current environment to
get people to think two thoughts at once
it's really hard to break away from this
sense of like can I still care about
that and care about this or am I having
to choose and unfortunately where it's
framed is it very often is a choice so
even if it's not as resource Zero Sum
and let's be clear sometimes it could be
right if there's only so much money to
spend on education say and some of it
does go for policies that are pro mail
which I would argue For You could argue
that that means less money is going into
some of the money for women scholarships
into stem or whatever it is okay so I
think you have to be honest about that I
would argue that that's now Justified
but it's a deeper problem than that it's
more just almost in the in the
conversation
you've got to pick sides and that merely
saying
boys and men are in trouble we need to
do to help more as a boys and men is to
betray any commitment to the needs of
women and girls and that false binary is
a really crippling the conversation I
think around this subjects one of the
reasons I wrote the book honestly is
because I just didn't see that many good
faith attempts to try and do this to try
and think two thoughts at once and say
okay create a permission space for a
conversation around this which does not
require people to give up previous
commitments but also opens their eyes to
the fact there are some pretty big
gender inequalities running the other
way now and so you have to decide are
you interested in inequality or you're
interested in girls and women and if
you're interested in girls and women
because that's what you care about you
that's what your institution does fine
but then we do need countervailing
institutions or policies that take the
other gender inequalities seriously we
can't just look through one eye I think
this very much has a social signaling
stated preferences thing going on as
well that
a lot of women at the moment a lot of
people that are pushing for the
upholding of women and the pushing
forward for the progression that they
can have in terms of access to education
employment Family Support so on
are not thinking sufficiently deeply
about the problem do you not want your
daughters to grow up in a school where
they have strong male role models so
that they actually understand that they
don't need to fear men perhaps they come
from a fatherless home let's remember as
well that a lot of the policies are
chosen by people in the upper Elites and
yet they must harshly impact the people
that are poverty-stricken it's very much
a disparity between those that make the
rules and those that follow the rules
would it not be better for your sons
that you have to be able to grow up with
good examples good role models in and
around school the grandfather that
you've got that you care about that's
going to be looked after would it not be
better for the daughters that you have
that you say that you're trying to make
the world better for to have some
partners that they can actually respect
and contend with someone that's going to
be a competent caring well-respected
well-contributing Father Figure partner
in life Breadwinner whatever it might be
it seems like
not understanding the challenges that
are facing men
and boys
is putting women at a disadvantage as
well do you really want your daughters
to be in school with boys that can't sit
still and are so disruptive that that
must lead to worse education outcomes
for the girls that are in class with
them as well
that's why I think yeah that's exactly
that's why I think redshirting you know
boys or starting boys will be good for
girls actually it's one of the reasons
parents very often put their girls into
Single Sex schools if they get the
option twos is to get them away from the
disruptions that the boys have but I
think I think you're raising quite a
deep Point here which is how we think
about human flourishing across different
groups and
outside of a very small separatist part
of the feminist movement I don't think
many women would disagree
with pretty much everything you've just
said right including those who would
consider themselves card carrying
feminists right do they want boys and
men to flourish do they want their
husbands to be doing well do they want
their brothers to be doing what they
want yes they would say yes he's yes to
to all all of the above
um
the question then is
do you agree that some of them are
struggling
okay do you agree that some of the
reasons they're struggling are not just
their own individual frailties like some
like as we discussed it's not just a
psychological problem with your son it's
the problem with the school system
right do you agree with that there are
structural things here okay thirdly do
you agree we should do something about
those
in order to try and help boys and men
succeed we've got to go through all
three of those stages I think a lot of
people are at stage one some people at
stage two I'm hoping to get people to
stage three which is okay let's do some
stuff about this then let's let's do
some stuff to to help if we agree there
is this strand of utopian feminism which
has always been about female only
societies
and and you see it back from Charlotte
uh Perkins her land
uh all the way through to that Rick and
Morty episode
um what's it raising
Gaza gazza's Thorpe or something another
one yeah where the guys are all like
living as barbarians on the planet and
and then there's this kind of serene
Society above and they kind of it they
brutally kill them they throw the males
out and they just get them to inseminate
and stuff but it's actually like that
there's a lot of literature around this
and of course you know Wonder Woman from
an all-female all-female island the
Amazons and so on too and it's really
speaking to something I think which is
this idea that you could currently
create this perfect Society if only you
could kind of get rid of all the men
or some cording them off or put them on
a different planet or something like
that
um and it's always been an interesting
strand there's been much less of it
lately and of course the real world that
women want to live in is not a world
like that if you spoke to most women
they don't want to live in the world
without men they want to live in a world
where men are doing well and men treat
them well and they treat men well the
world you just described so well
um and so assuming that men and women
are going to continue to live together
and they're going to be lots of men and
women around
than helping each other to flourish is
surely the project here and for a very
long time that has meant paying a lot
more attention to women and girls and in
lots of the world that is still true I
wouldn't want to be misunderstood here I
don't think there's a big market for my
argument in Afghanistan
but in many parts of the world it's
absolutely true now that for to help
women flourish and kids to flourish we
need to help men to flourish as well
Richard Reeves ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out what you do and
keep up to date with your work where
should they go
as you go to my website which is
richardvreves.com I have a sub stack
which is called of boys and men where I
post weekly on on the particular themes
check out the Brookings website where my
scholarship is I'm on Twitter same
Richard V Reeves and it's been a great
conversation Chris I really appreciate
this thank you I appreciate you too
thanks Richard what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]